has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continued to trash her
okay i'm done with this no no no sorry
no actually do you know what that's
possible
maybe not mine no no no no no no no i'm
being sorry
that's piers morgan storming off the set
of good morning britain
on tuesday after his colleague alex
biersford
called him out on air sorry because
absolutely diabolical behavior piers has
had a lot of
stick over um what many i think
perceived to be his
relentless bashing of harry and megan
and you'll see if you follow him on
twitter
friends just will often tweet just leave
them alone well piers is an argument is
no
they don't want to be left alone they're
putting themselves in the public eye
and you know i'm gonna go for them and
he and he has stuff repeatedly
on monday piers slammed the duchess of
sussex on the morning show for her
tell-all interview with oprah winfrey
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says meghan markle that's a problem i
wouldn't believe it if she read my
weather report
and the fact that she's fired up
onslaught against our royal family
i think is contemptible well it was that
tirade against megan and her husband
prince harry that had alex all worked up
i understand that you don't like meghan
markle you've made it so clear a number
of times on this program
a number of times and i understand that
you've got a personal relationship
with mega market or had one and she cut
you off
she's entitled to cut you off if she
wants to has she said anything about you
since she cut you off
i don't think she has but yet you
continued to trash her
sorry absolutely diabolical behavior
you see i'm sorry but pierce spouts off
on a regular basis and we all have to
sit there
and listen 6 30 to 7 o'clock yesterday
was incredibly hard to watch
i think the feeling to piers is quite
simple over here in britain
he's a bit like marmite too you either
love him or you hate him
but pierce he dishes it out he's got to
be able to take it too i think there was
quite a lot of surprise
when he took his mic off and stormed out
the studio today
after getting a bit of a talking to you
or dressing down
from his weatherman later the
55-year-old journalist took to twitter
to respond to people
who were calling him out for being a
hypocrite after years of digging into
guests
and co-presenters on the show piers
wrote i
just prefer not to sit there listening
to colleagues call me diabolical
he adds that he went for a little cool
down but later came back to have a
discussion
i just want you also to be aware
of the power of your words and i'm not
saying that you're
a racist but what are you saying yeah
pierce came back to the set and
continued his debate with alex
it's important for me and you to have
this conversation let's just not just
make it personal
it's fine it's not pro you made it well
let's move on
it's hard because you know what we talk
we talk personally about
um you know people on this show and we
give our opinions on them don't we so
actually sometimes it does come back at
you we have to be
you know it's fine it's just the way it
was done we can disagree about that
tensions have been running very very
high here
peers were shouting the guests were
shouting tensions were running high i
would imagine that peers probably
haven't slept through the night i think
you know many journalists at the moment
are probably running on
empty following the heated on-air
exchange itv confirmed via a statement
on their website that pierce is
leaving good morning britain